country star Kacey Musgraves recently
took home four Grammy Awards including
album of the year for her fourth studio
album golden hour while most artists
within the country genre have kept quiet
on the LGBTQ community Casey has been an
outspoken ally since her debut studio
album same trailer different Park
[Music]
follow your arrow supports queer
positivity and when I chatted with KC
way back in 2013 I asked her if she
feared with the response to the song
would be where he worried what country
radio might think about stuff like that
I think that I think about aren't you
know there aren't big deals to me I
don't really think that they should beat
anyone else I think it's just life and
we all live it and we're all inspired
but we're all driven by the same
emotions you know gay straight black
white whatever it is but it's like it's
only a big deal if you make it a big
deal and now I just I just want to put
good music out you know 2014 Casey made
history becoming the first country
artist to perform at New York's GLAAD
Media Awards to celebrate the release of
her sophomore album pageant material in
2015 Casey hosted a listening party and
dragged show in Nashville
[Music]
in 2017 Casey wrote a love letter to the
LGBTQ community for billboard where she
explains she wasn't always so
open-minded and what changed her views
Casey ended the love letter was saying
to all my friends in the LGBTQ community
thank you well the career stuff is great
it's fleeting you changed me as a human
last year while speaking about the
relationship between the LGBTQ community
and country music at a festival she said
it's crazy that a certain kind of person
could feel excluded from a genre that's
so real or supposed to be so real that
has always really pissed me off because
I love the genre so much I felt well
fine maybe I'll just have an all-gay
audience in late 2018 Casey was a guest
judge on the fourth season of RuPaul's
Drag Race all-stars furthering her
status as an LGBTQ icon and our favorite
country Quinn you are a great songwriter
you are your first really stood out to
me just last week Casey welcomed the two
yeah the two newly crowned winners from
the show in person on stage with her in
LA for the first time with their crowns
Trinity the Tuck and Monet exchange
Casey's latest single and video rainbow
is another giant kiss to the LGBTQ
community the music video features a
teen wrestling with gender identity Oh
like Africa take a look around
everything is alright now
cuz the sky is finally open the rain
wind stopped blowing
in a recent interview Casey says she
hopes the song serves as an anthem for
the LGBTQ community
saying I feel a kinship and friendship
with that community adding I will always
be an ally and strong supporter
look we need artists like Casey to
continue to support the LGBTQ community
especially in a genre like country music
where the support is undeniably lacking
I worked in country music for over ten
years and I can say that the genre is
full of the most incredibly talented
hard-working and cool people behind the
scenes there are so many people from the
LGBTQ community working hard with these
artists from songwriters to glam teams
so do I personally wish more country
artists would speak out and show support
yeah I do
[Music]
do you think Casey is a great voice for
the LGBTQ community should more country
or to show their support why do you
think so many country artists keep quiet
about their LGBTQ views let me know in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]